something pretty cool has been growing
in the heart of California's capital
it's a new 500 million dollar arena for
the NBA Sacramento Kings the golden one
Center when the stadium is completed
this fall they hope it'll be so
outrageously technologically advanced
that it will even Wow fans from Silicon
Valley and not just the fans inside this
arena will be open to all we have doors
that are 60 feet tall 150 feet wide
literally airplane hangar doors that
will open up and really blur the lines
between are you watching a game or an
event inside or watching a game or an
event outside the entire experience will
be intimately tied to the team's
app you'll use it to buy tickets but it
will also tell you where it's easiest to
park and how to get around the King's
say you can even use it to order hotdogs
delivered right to your seat of course
and if watching replays on the 84 foot
screen isn't your thing
the app will pipe video and stats into
your phone and you won't even have to
use your own data the golden one Center
will also be studded with hundreds of
Wi-Fi access points but providing
internet for over 17,000 fans is how
should we say daunting so the arena will
come complete with its own 6,000 square
foot data center to handle the load the
golden one Center will be the world's
most connected arena we have two 100 Gig
pipes coming into the arena and what
that means for the fans is that they
will be able to upload 225,000 Instagram
photos per second or half a million
snapchats per second that incredible
power is all the more impressive
considering the arena is planned to be
100% solar-powered and instead of a
bunch of giant air conditioners hanging
above the stands are cooled from below
which the team says is more efficient
that means the people in a given section
may one day be able to vote to set their
temperature now how's that for a fan
experience